Okay. So now we turn to a big topic
when you use Datastore, queries. And we will start
by giving you an overview of the types of
queries that we will run. Let's do that by looking
at Conference Central, where we will build out the
show conferences function. In the first tab here, we
can see all the conferences. This query is called
query by kind, because we will search for all entities
that are of the conference kind. In the
second tab, we can see all the conferences
created by the user. This query is called
query by kind, filter by ancestor, because we will
search for all conferences that have the user
as their ancestor. Remember, this is the ancestor
relationship we established between the conference, and the
profile that created the conference. And finally, in the
third tab we will see all conferences the
user has registered to attend. This query is
called query by kind filter by property, because
we will display all conferences that are in the
attended conference property of the profile entity. Remember,
this is to has a relationship we created
between a profile and the conferences they registered
to attend. And one more thing. In this part,
you can further restrict the search result by
applying filters. And as you can see from the
drop down menu, these are properties in the
conference kind. So therefore, these will also be a
query by kind, filtered by property. Okay. So
these are the query types we will look at
now. Query by kind, query by kind filtered by
ancestor, query by kind filtered by property. The query
by kind filtered by property, is a little bit advanced stuff. The other ones
are pretty straight forward though, so you'll
start off by adding them to Conference Central.